The amazing thing about this pandemic compared with all previous pandemics...
...is the amount of data we have.
The results show that the world is never going to be the same again.
The world before the pandemic is gone.
We're not going back to it.
The big question is, to what extent are things going to snap back?
We're not gonna snap back all the way.
It's clear that people aren't going to go on doing...
...all the things they've been doing in the pandemic.
But nor are they gonna go back to the way things were before.
So, the answer is going to be somewhere in the middle.
And exactly where it is in the middle is going to vary by country,...
...by activity, by industry, by household.
And so, that's what makes it so unpredictable.
Possibly one of the biggest long-term changes from the pandemic...
...is going to be more people working from home.
Our index shows that office occupancy is rising...
...but it probably won't ever rise to pre-pandemic levels.
Companies will probably let people work from home or the office.